I've recently been hosting free use
orgies or or juice where a consent is
assumed by default when you enter and of
course you can revoke it anytime or go
over a whole bunch of rules to make sure
it's very safe you like have wristbands
so nobody's actually doing anything they
don't want to but in those ones you have
to have more men than women I thought
free use was like
consensual like at any time
but it's at any time within the
constraints of this building or
something like that you yeah so at the
orgies it's like you buy entering if you
wear a wristband uh then you are like by
default opting into consent so people
don't have to like do a thing where they
negotiate with you and like to be like
is this okay it's just the default is
like you just go for it and if they want
you to stop they say the safer like red
don't and then you have to stop
um and we do like exercise in the
beginning of people saying red to make
sure that everybody knows exactly what
the rules are what's your favorite safe
word red right when I first started
doing like weird kinky [__] I was like
oh let's make a safer and we pick the
word foliage I was like that's goofy
right and then but then it eventually
came a time where I did actually in fact
want to say the safe word and I couldn't
I was like like in agony I was like
crying like I can't make myself say this
stupid word right now
foliage so after that it's like red
doesn't matter I don't care it's not
funny we're just going with very simple
very practical